[Music]
and welcome to the attitude era
of jk news baby all right we've got a
very very special hot seat today
we have julia chow in the hot beat today
with even hotter questions but we always
like to start it off really really cold
and or lukewarm with master bart go
ahead
what after barter the difference between
a frog and a toad
oh uh
i don't know is it the size
for you to answer
the ocean
i just found this channel
i think i just reached into my cupboard
for a thing of popcorn
i got a good qual uh a question
a cold question i got a really good cold
question all right this is such an
interesting
chair for to be questioning it's a
throne and it's a hot seat part of the
engineer i got i got a good cold
question okay okay all right
so
what protects
against covet better
a yellow mask or a red mask
neither
those look like hats
that looks orange well i just didn't
have any masks that were yellow and red
we're gonna keep the cold questions over
with clark
and uh
if we cut that out a yellow mask okay
let's uh let's uh it's hot see let's ask
some questions all right
um we got to stay stay lukewarm so uh
you have to change your hair color uh
what's the next color oh yeah that's a
good one it's a really really good one i
want to know
orange
do you get
com do you do people
assume you are lesbian
because of your hair color what if the
question was do people assume you're a
lesbian and that was it yeah
uh some people do okay okay are they
fellow lesbians that are hitting on you
or are they just like people that assume
you're like are they making out with you
or sitting on your head
i don't know i feel like it's a mix
it feels like a mix there's like a good
amount of guys are like are you like
lesbian and i'm like no that's all they
ask me yeah they asked me like straight
up if i'm lesbian or if i'm interested
in girls and i'll be like no
this is like this is when i had like
really long hair those are just anime
fans do you ask them why they ask you
that
uh sometimes yeah
slowly are they they just they just like
we don't see you with anyone so we just
thought that you're not into guys and
i'm like oh okay so on this show we all
believe in like uh equal rights for
women
wow not to brag but yeah
so we just want to treat you fairly as
all and uh everybody who comes into the
hot seat we say the same thing so uh
would you rather have sex with your mom
or your dad
neither of them
there's a gun to your face and a gun to
your mom and her dad's face and if you
say you know all three triggers are
pulled and there's a streamy over a bowl
of boiling acids
we're gonna get the streamy but we might
not get it if you don't answer this all
i had to answer it's gonna be dropped to
the submission deadline is august 8th be
serious you have to be serious we all
answered seriously too yeah you want me
to tone it down one notch no no you want
to give us
that's one of the questions that david
also no sex sex sex exactly
i'm just women's rights here right okay
sex um
you have to you have to we've all
answered this question you're taking too
long they all they all went
we've had doctors and lawyers answer
this question on the show save orphans
all over the world
you have to do it
go with your gut feeling three agents
two my mom
oh your mom
and you say you're not a lesbian
speak up for you why your wife why are
your mommy uh
mommy
is it because it's because of her mommy
milkers
actually my mom doesn't have them
anymore oh what happened to them breast
cancer
did you chop them all off yeah she tried
both she got the nipple still this is a
video i have no idea you don't know if
your mom's nipples my mom let me see her
body i don't [ __ ] know what's going
on but did you you never got curious and
asked her thank god my mom had breast
cancer too
that's all i gotta say yeah
but did you ask her did you ever ask
you never asked i would have asked
that was a poem dude joe in a video by
himself for a second
question for my mom and she had a tough
time with it so well i'm glad she's over
and she's alive yes yes shout out to
your mom yeah big time
[Applause]
but uh yeah i would do her because i
think i'm a lot closer to her than me
don't say like that's emotional it's too
real too real
why and i'm telling you guys i know
we're talking to a big-time perv
i'm sorry i thought you guys could
handle these answers
don't say i would do her just because
i'm dressed like i can handle it doesn't
matter i can handle it
we're still very sensitive to him he's
porcupining you know he's like a he's
like a gangster soft interior
celebrity crush
oh um oh
i don't think i have one say jason momoa
popular choice
yeah who would you who would you do
right now if like you just had the
chance to you but i will rip his clothes
off and [ __ ] tickle his nipples would
it be a k-pop star k-pop
anime character
i hear jackson wang is pretty popular
cartoon you can pick a cartoon you can
pick a technical monster if you like
who's telling them
is not off the table totally fine oh
interesting um you want him to take you
on a date you guys could get some boba
and then you [ __ ] vibe so well and
then you're just like take me home right
now and he [ __ ] grabs you like this
put you against the wall and you [ __ ]
grab bulba and you drink it together
like this that's nice um i guess oh man
okay i think the only one i can think
about right now is from fruits basket
it's an anime oh wow yeah i mean what
look is that yeah
yo does he have hands or or is he more
wiggly than that
on a scale of one to ten how buff is he
uh i don't know in the anime they made
him look really lean yeah most of the
fruits pass you guys are no why would
you pick
are you blushing right now why are you
blushing no
i know what you're talking about
this guy is [ __ ] that guy you like
gingerbread that's why you said orange
hair okay
it was a subconscious thing whoa wow
you're like orange you're gonna be
matching with kyo julia likes real
sidekick looking fellas
okay let me ask you a real question
um
you've been away from jk for a while yes
on the street do people still recognize
you from jk and when they bring that up
and they haven't been updated because
they're not [ __ ] watching the goddamn
show what do you say to them
oh uh do you plug our show okay do they
go oh my god julia from chicken party
yeah you ate a tarantula oh and then
what goes from there uh i'd be like yeah
what's up they're like you know usually
i don't know i've had fan encounters but
nothing like that though fan encounter
sounds spicy a lot of super spicy
a lot of the times um when they say oh
you know like i used to watch jk a lot
the first thing of you like used to
what's going on there oh you're repping
for us that's awesome
you should [ __ ] punch him in the
throat not even in the face just go poop
ah
but it could be acceptable i did have an
artist that i was working with um
when she was ending her her job like she
was telling me oh yeah by the way i hope
this isn't awkward but um i used to like
uh watch you on jk isn't it more awkward
at the end though like i would rather
start the relationship with hey just to
let you know loved your [ __ ] and then
you finished the job and you were like
we're cool but at the end of the job
like after knowing them for like five
years and then you're like by the way
actually no like a lot of a lot of the
people i like that voice it's a mix
because some people would straight up
say it and then some people would just
hold it till the end when they like
leave yeah very respectful that's nice
they're pretty responsible okay i'm
gonna turn the heat i'm gonna turn this
um do you you have now had other bosses
than and joe how do you rate bart and
joe as bosses and why and i got another
heater question after that
you don't work for them anymore you
don't [ __ ] need to say what the [ __ ]
you what that's right whatever the [ __ ]
you watch we actually appreciate
honestly
really really i really like my current
boss like he's really cool he let me get
take like a month off
so uh every year you had a month off
with us remember which was fully paid
but okay go ahead go ahead just talk
about just
just just talk about whatever you need
to do you need to hold a safe space you
need to witness objection okay also they
don't let me like they don't you know
they don't have they don't ask me to do
like crazy things or like clean up
brandon which you missed by the way you
told us earlier you missed doing that
didn't say she missed that part i'm not
i'm a backup i'm gonna let her speak i'm
a letter i miss the chaos okay but you
know i gotta say i enjoy i enjoy just
working from certain hours to certain
hours and then just relaxing for the
rest what's wrong with from 1 to 24.
so military i like it
i like how earlier julia said in a video
you can all see this video but she's
basically like yeah i really miss this
place i miss just like i never know
what's going to happen next yeah and
then joe's like yeah don't you miss like
you just have to clean up my poop and
she's like yeah that's literally not
what i what i'm saying i missed actually
it's not one of my best memories there's
other things about it i miss just how
random you guys are but not not the
cleaning of the poop or the pew okay my
follow-up question is this joe would
poop the floor sometimes yeah the floor
yeah
sometimes i mean it was just i had ibs
and you know julia was sweet enough to
kind of like just clean up after me like
uh
i i used to be called joberman but like
yeah they used to be called hey the
jobberman's [ __ ] doing his thing
again just randomly like
yeah just having to like reach out to
people that like i'm not very close with
but bart and joe are really close with
they're like oh hey stranger to
coordinate yeah it's like hi what you do
now that you produce right today's video
is brought to you by babble all right so
2023
if
the world gets a little bit more stable
right i got plans because originally
this is what i was going to do with
hannah we were going to go do this train
ride from portugal all the way to
vietnam
what yeah is all the way down there it's
not one train ride but then it's like
routes where you connect from one to
another and it goes all throughout these
different countries and i was like you
know what be kind of cool is we spend
time all throughout europe and like
visit every kind of
place
and like just stay for a couple days and
i was like
would also be cool is to be there and
talk to the people like not in english
but like try to blend in with the locals
and the native tongue and the native
tuck yeah and that's why it's pretty
awesome because babel i can actually do
this where their lessons are only like
15 minutes and they have 14 different
languages that i can choose from which
most of it is around the european area
where i'm gonna be at yeah and what's
awesome is they use a hundred and fifty
language experts to create these lessons
so it's phrases and words that are
highly used rather than like the more in
theory type of stuff like i remember
when i first took spanish i learned how
to say like business card or something
and maybe back in the day yeah maybe
back in the day because it was like
tarjeta or something like maybe back in
the day uh learning those formal words
are more uh convenient but now if you go
straight to spain or mexico or wherever
the chance of using a word like that is
very little you're probably going to ask
where's the bathroom you know yeah
but the cool thing is you can even have
conversations
as fast as like in within three weeks of
learning so like
babble's pretty cool especially if
you're trying to learn like multiple
languages and me i want to be a polygon
one day right now i'm bilingual i want
to be trilingual and quadlingo and
whatever lingual and i think by that
point i'll be a polygon
and also they got a a 20-day money-back
guarantee which is pretty awesome so you
could try it and you're like man
i am get i ain't getting my polygon as
fast as i want then you can also get a
refund that's cool right now you can
save up to 60 off your subscription when
you go to babel.com off the record
that's babble.com off the record for up
to 60 off your subscription babble
language for life uh kind of you know
it's a little different though i don't
have that responsibility my boss does it
for me oh yeah okay i wanted to ask you
a question um
coming from jk which is a [ __ ] wild
wild west like a crazy startup
environment right to a probably way more
legit by the books environment um what
were some things that you think
jk really prepared you for and what were
some things that jk crazy under prepared
you for oh uh she's like did you say
underprepared
uh
prepared me for is like just kind of
like the unexpected
yeah because i feel like
no matter what like or if anyone were to
say anything like crazy i'd be like oh
okay they're like sorry we didn't mean
that i'm like
like i give a [ __ ] like you can say
whatever this is the navy seal of
production companies yeah yeah yeah you
got a thick skin no in corporate america
some people are just like well you know
i can't really say it and then like
damn
i
said it oh my god you're so bad don't
tell h.r
oh my gosh i think going with the flow
is is what you guys probably prepared me
for for a long life skill yeah yeah a
lot of times i was just going with the
flow and then not to like freak out so
much
and then what i feel underprepared for
is the amount of sheets we have
sheets like paperwork yeah like um like
call sheets uh not like call sheets but
just like um bed sheets no
like more sheets sheets for like
tracking things
like records yeah records like all those
things also like you're in like an
organized place yup
we have no paperwork here just word of
mouth you can steal money from this
place i do
yeah we all do
i take a camera i take a battery i take
a [ __ ] sound piece it's happened
before let's put it on ebay a similar
question uh to follow that up what was
both and you can answer in any order
your
absolute favorite thing about being here
and then also you're literally like
the thing you hated most about doing
that you hate how about make it an
incident too like what was that yeah
yeah
yeah um
highlight in low light
[Music]
i have so many i don't even know where
to start
[ __ ] you guys okay okay i think maybe
just start both stories they'll start
the the high incidence with bart and
start with the lowest
oh god i think i think the the simplest
example would be um when we were filming
jk party
and um we got into a food fight
that was really the one here or the one
over here i didn't know where that was
going and i got sriracha in my eye yes
and it's and then the sriracha is all
over [ __ ] bobby lee yeah right here
yes
those spots are when i squeezed sriracha
everywhere yeah and it was like moment
it was like that brown stuff creature
yeah and bobby lee painted this that's
what old sriracha looks like
wow okay yeah so that was a high point i
just remember no well i mean like i'm
just saying like a very easy example
that's a two in one is that it was
really fun because it was very impromptu
and it was just very spontaneous and
everybody was just having a lot of fun
which i really enjoyed
part of that was that i should have
started with the low man what the [ __ ]
the low part of that was there was a
mess afterwards and the next morning we
had jk news and it was like there's no
way we could film so then there was like
the stress of it where it's like oh so
great that we're having fun guys
but it's we're having too much fun that
we we didn't think it through we didn't
we didn't think this all through it
smelled the next time yeah it did it did
it was really messy that sounds like fun
though yeah and you had to you had to
clean it up
oh we actually had to get cleaners
cleaner whoa usually we get the team to
clean it clean it up it was so bad that
we had to actually hire professionals
that's nice yeah we found some like
24-hour [ __ ] like carpet steamer
people type people oh it was so bad were
they like holy [ __ ] it's just like all
the low the low points of jk include
like
it's cleaning
it's all cleaning
that's why we [ __ ] love jk we don't
clean [ __ ] here that's why this place is
[ __ ] nasty yeah i clean i guess the
other low part would just be i don't
really get to see you guys as much
anymore oh true well you're welcome too
you know did you know that uh that that
this place is a place that you could
come in and sit down at too and like be
a part of so i could just come in
randomly yep anytime it happens all the
time we might not be here but you're
totally welcome oh so what if
you have the key
what if i just come in on like a random
jk music sure yeah david did that like
three weeks ago
yeah seven people at jk the whole day
david was like i don't wanna [ __ ] sit
in traffic so he just sat down with us
and i'm like you're not scheduled and
you're not gonna get paid but whatever
he had a blast like that i think yeah
definitely to recap the highest is just
when we just all have fun and it's just
it work doesn't feel like work and then
i think the low parts is um cleaning
cleaning and also a loss of direction at
times
oh oh explain yes let's go hot seat
right here
burner's up burner's up
i don't know like
barton joe you guys got to make up your
minds okay
like there have been so many times where
like you know detroit and i were like
what do you guys want to do you guys
want to go into this direction you just
want to go this direction you're like i
don't know we kind of want to explore
both i'm like okay if we expert both
then um you know we're not quite sure
like how one one is going to do well
than the other we should probably just
spend more in one area and then you know
we get hit with you guys can figure it
out and we're like
and they're like okay we're really
excited about this new direction let's
have a meeting about it in two and a
half months
that's not our fault on a friday morning
at 5 30 a.m
5 30.
yeah the laugh is because it's true
who's small disney
it's your it's literally your phone
that's what you're saying one of these
guys that we were trying to schedule all
of a sudden has a bunch of gigs or
something in the middle of august dang
nick for
me and joe are ready to meet next week
or even this week hey in september in
september
[Music]
i remember
oh oh i just i just got hit with a
memory about danger boys the trauma okay
i remember i remember so we were we were
trying to figure out a month to film and
we had three months to choose from which
was uh i think it's annie minnie monty
mower
that's the professional answer i think
it was like uh september
september
come on
wait i think it was yeah like september
october or november i think it was like
one of those months and i just remember
being told that
bart and joe are ready to go whenever
within these months it just depends on
the other talent you know why because
they're prioritizing danger boys number
one on the list go ahead of course
that's right right and so then i
remember so so we're getting these
people locked in
and then all of a sudden
the availability was gone
and then because barney and joe were
like oh we can't do it this time we got
to do this i'm like
but you guys told me
oh i think you i think you came back in
a month or something hmm he came back a
month later you're like hey i got the
scheduling a month later i was all those
days are booked now no
i came to the meeting that you guys
booked a month and a half from now
it was it was these set days and then i
remember you guys were like we need more
days to practice and i was like what
happened to all of these other days
that's tim's fault then does tim
delagato can't remember scripts
save space guys safe space i just i just
remember feeling very stressed about it
i was like wow
i don't know what's going on i was just
told that i was doing this i was just
following this and all of a sudden
everything was
like you're stressing out julia you
can't be doing that
i'm confused too because i'll remember
so i will concede to you
[Laughter]
i was there and um just just a little
lost because i was like i don't
understand i'm just following directions
and all of a sudden i feel like i'm
getting i'm getting blamed for it well
not really blamed but like i just felt
like i wasn't doing my job right
well because you have to deal with the
consequences so you're being blamed
because of the circumstances that make
sense yeah but like no one was like
straight i was like this is your fault
it was just more of like well i told
brandon not to say that
man brandon
i'm telling you you see this is why we
got to keep things in-house with jk
and [ __ ] yoshi yeah yoshi came in and
started messing it all up and
[Laughter]
through all that trauma that you went
through at jk bart and joe weren't here
hypothetically
if you wanted them to just say something
if you wanted them to apologize anything
what would you have them say to make you
feel better
i'll tell you i'm sorry julia
i have no [ __ ] memory of anything
this is beautiful
i think we're progressing here i'm not
even gonna gaslight you because i can't
even gaslight you and tell you that
you're wrong because i don't [ __ ]
remember
so much [ __ ] i don't know if that's
helping
i remember talking about i remember
everything tell me what you want me to
say sorry for and then we'll have a
cliffhanger ending so i'll say sorry and
then the other part two very nice that's
the best we need views now we can get
more views out of there we marked out
two videos
out of one concept okay okay um
hmm
uh
to apologize for
she's like like she's making a real girl
rolodex anything you want i get one
apology which one am i getting what's
gonna be most worth it fine you get two
apologies there two apologies wow
i'll say sorry as many times you were
[ __ ] awesome
oh we're we're breaking ground okay yeah
wow
let's give her some glasses i don't
remember [ __ ] now you're awesome
she's one of she's one of the few people
that i'm like um if all else fails at
life you're always welcome to come back
and i've told you this and i said even
if you don't want to be back you have a
permanent place here
and that's why i was like even last time
you said you left but i didn't leave you
you're a part of jk oh whether you like
it or not okay thank you and so in my
eyes julia has always been stellar and i
knew that after leaving jk you were
gonna absolutely crush it outside
because for her you know she's the type
of person that always [ __ ]
goes and does it a thousand percent
never half asses so i was like that
character
no no matter what any any any [ __ ]
boss is going to love that and that's
why you stayed here for so long not
because i just suck at firing people but
really it's like
really nice really nice oh julia that's
a good one you deserve it though you
know you you really did contribute and
you were a part of it like and you
[ __ ] crushed it here
yeah you are jacob yeah i'll take that
i'll take her okay i'll take that bart
i don't remember [ __ ] but
it's really good that's what's like
being in your relationship with joe it's
like hey here's how you [ __ ] up
yourself i don't remember you but you
know why you're [ __ ] the best yeah
the best person i ever met my whole life
you're incredible you're absolutely
[ __ ] incredible and then like what
are they gonna say to that it's like uh
yeah i don't know that's nice to know
because i felt like a lot of the times i
was like oh i feel like i'm messing up
dodging what made you feel that way ah i
don't know
i have to think about it yeah i think so
or is it because of that big [ __ ]
record button right there
no i don't know
you